okay real quick some of you heard my
story yesterday about fainting on the
plane back from my vacation in Italy I
went into detail about that I will just
mention a few of the more popular
moments on my Instagram feed from my
trip of course I'm on instagram at david
dot pakman if you follow me there you
were able to follow along with my entire
trip the ups downs the bizarre an
outrageous driving of the Amalfi Coast
and so much more uh first picture i will
show you here which did really really
well this is my first day this was my
I'm pretending not to be incredibly
jetlagged face drinking a cappuccino and
having this is it may look like a
croissant but in Italy these are not
croissants these are core Nettie uh it's
basically a croissant I i I've sampled
them extensively and that's the
determination I've made uh that is one
of the more popular pictures from the
vacation week and then also closer to
the end of the trip another picture that
people really seem to like this is me in
the very picturesque city of Sorrento
big confusion around Sorrento which is
some people think sorrento is part of
the amalfi coast but it is not it is
actually part of the metropolitan city
of Naples because it is on the north
side of the physical mass uh that that
is uh also includes the Amalfi Coast I
did go to some amalfi coast towns and
cities posit on Oh amalfi and some other
really little towns everybody told me
you're going to love pasta tano I really
found it to be outrageously touristy and
I much more enjoyed the town of Amalfi
which again I was warned by some Amalfi
is more touristy I didn't see it that
way I really didn't uh follow me on
Instagram david dot Pakman a lot of
really really great pictures from my
trip that i know a lot of people were of
keeping up with and following